Hello Freak bitches.
I remember I was,
I met an older dude and we were,
we were,
he was cool guy.
We hung out.
That's how it starts.
I always starts with older dude.
We're in Wisconsin sweatsuit,
we're in Wisconsin,
the northwoods of Wisconsin.
Summertimes and I remember I meet
this guy and there was this girl,
they're all two girls
older and we were like,
oh,
we were there.
I don't know,
who cares?
Let's say 14,
13 or 14.
It was so hot and I was 11,
10 something beyond even younger,
younger because I'll tell you why.
I know I was younger.
So I am hanging out with this guy and uh,
we can we keep.
We keep.
And I'm,
I was sexual pervert.
How old is he?
Well,
I'll tell you open.
I'm going to tell you how
I know he was a lot older.
Ready?
This is how you,
this is,
this is why I'm going.
This is the point.
So we start.
I actually say we should try to have
sex with those girls trying to conspire.
I don't know how old I was
or at least I was like,
we should try to see their boobs.
I don't know what I was
saying to me because.
Yes,
that's a great plan.
So we're talking,
he goes calm.
We have to go into the woods
and come up with a plan.
So No.
Yeah,
so I'm like,
alright,
so we go to the God damn it.
No wonder you've been molested several.
The next thing I know this
is coming through now.
The next time that he pulled his pants
down and I noticed how Harry is assets.
So I go,
that's weird if there is,
there's this dick and his ass.
And he had,
he lies down and he goes,
do you wanna do you wanna
rub on top of me or no?
And I go,
I don't think so.
I was like,
rub on me or no,
I was young.
I was young enough to have to think about.
Imagine if that's like fucking go to la.
I swear to God,
you know,
how do you get these
kids to fuck you dude,
this is all you have to do.
You lie down and you go,
do you want to rub on top of me?
I know I can always just start fucking
spit on your asshole
and start paddling away.
They all do it.
It's like hypnosis.
He laid down with great.
It wasn't like he was bent lakes.
Right.
They,
you want to rub on top of me,
you know,
and I go,
I don't think I was just curious.
Yeah.
I saw the crack and I was like,
I was like,
do I say yes?
this is vaguely sexual.
And I go,
no,
I don't think so.
So then he gets up and he goes,
all right,
well just hold off for
a second and he starts,
I'm going to show you something.
And I go,
all right.
He starts jerking off and I go,
I go,
I take all my Tutu to.
I used to rubbing as my mother called her.
So,
um,
I go,
so he's,
he's,
he's winking off and that
was the first time he goes,
hold on,
ready,
ready?
And I go,
yeah,
and he comes on you.
He busted in your face,
not on my face.
He just shoot and I go,
what the fuck?
I go,
what's that white?
I couldn't believe it.
Seeing white stuff is the
first time I saw somebody.
A jacket.
Oh,
hold on.
She,
you were watching this do jack off in
the woods for a solid four minutes.
Hey Man.
And US courage ma'am.
What were you saying to them?
I don't remember.
It was so long ago.
He goes on.
Hold on.
You called this Mr. Yeah,
hold on.
He was like,
watch this.
Wait,
wait,
wait a minute.
Hold on.
Wait for it.
And it's going to happen.
And then we went.
Then we left and we went
and spy on those girls.
You hung out with them after that?
I did assured that you watched a
grown man Jack off bus near you.
Not on your face.
Then you went to go find chicks.
Know what man?
When you were 11 years old.
Weird Shit can happen to you
to this 11 year old hockey.
Hell No.
You got lucky.
But I'm not saying that
would have happened.
You would've stood around
with a guy jerked off.
But I am saying it's possible that a guy,
when you were 11,
could've lied down and say,
Hey,
you want to rub on top of mayor know?
And you would have been like,
what the fuck?
Yeah.
It's good to have fatty foods is fun.
Sometimes it's not.
It's not.
I don't believe it's good to miss out on
all the pleasures in life because some
people get hooked on them.
I sing.
I think that's horseshit.
I agree.
Like Bacon is fucking delicious.
I'm not quitting.
I will never stop eating bacon.
It's not going to fucking happen.
It's too good.
When I sit there and I'm chewing
on a crispy piece of Bacon,
this cooked maybe just a little too long,
but it's just crunching on my mouth and
the saltiness and the sweetness of the
pig fat.
It's just warm and melting in
my mouth as I chew it down.
Breaking down the crispy fat.
I'm not.
I'm not stopping.
Never have any Naza.
If you bake bacon at like four,
25 or 20 minutes,
whatever it is,
the perfect.
I mean,
it's,
it's translucent and it melts in your
mouth and I swear to God of dictates like
that.
My Dad had bruised knees.
Like I fucking love Bacon.
I was telling Jay,
was I telling you today I haven't had a
bruised knees.
I fucking love that taste.
Well,
wolf is one of the Paleo Diet.
Pioneer guys wanted to just sort
of genius fitness health guy.
He slow cooks bacon every morning.
He's like,
it's a ritual.
He gets that fat bacon from wholefoods,
Bacon's dude,
and he puts on this fucking
slow bacon cooker and he's like,
as I'm getting ready for my day,
I'm going through my day.
It's smelling the Aromas,
filling the house.
It's like a,
there's a bunch of experiences going on.
I'm like,
God damn,
these poor vegans,
these poor bastards.
My wife,
my wife.
You know how like women have sense like
a woman to have a sense when you start
dating.
They were like,
oh,
shanice smells like strawberry.
Smells like Bacon.
I had a,
I had a chick one time,
it smelled like fucking Bologna.
He was like,
Adam Dana for two years process.
But uh,
but my wife's smells like Bacon every
morning she makes the same thing.
She's southern bacon,
eggs,
biscuits and fruit for the
kids every fucking morning.
Good call,
good call.
That's a good backrest.
My house reeks of bay.
I'd even take my bacon
game to the next level.
When you go to buy your Bacon,
if you buy it at like
just a regular story,
they have the thick cut you get.
Don't get the thick cut that spread out.
Like playing cards,
like,
like fanned out,
get the thick cut that's
packed in like dollar bills.
And then look at this.
You've got to make sure that the beginning
to the end of that thick cut is even.
You don't want any dips in it.
Go for fucking straight even.
That's the most amount of bacon
you can get for your money.
I'll take them my bay.
I'm taking my pink and pretty seriously
needs to go to a butcher.
That's when you take into the next level,
right?
When you're really taking the next level,
when you raise your own fucking pigs walk,
raise your own pigs,
get friendly with them and then
shoot them right in the head,
oh my God,
I'm going to lean my headlights into
your bedroom windows through blah blah,
blah,
redneck crazy redneck,
crazy for fuck.
But that.
I mean,
and people,
it's playing on pop radio because it
strikes a chord and I think some girls
think,
man,
he really was into,
you know,
he,
he really loved her because look at what
he's doing on the other side and that's
just the.
That's just a tricky little trap that
we got to transcend the least of my
concerns.
My concerns is that there'll be guys that
listened to it and think it's okay to
act like that if a girl is so
silly that she thinks all that.
He just loves him.
That's why he's all doing that.
Shooting up the house.
Shit.
You think he really wants to shoot up
it's fucking house and just letting her
know he loves
his women who grow up like that.
They all fucking black guy and there
having this conversation to their kid with
a Marlboro hanging out of
their mouth lists and sugar.
Your Dad and I have very passionate
relationship and I pushed his buttons and
you know,
and he loves me and if he didn't love me,
he wouldn't fucking hit me and I know
I don't make sense to you right now,
but someday we'll.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's this old paradigm that is in dire
need of transcendence and the need is
basically,
you know,
we have to be fully full.
I think Don Miguel Ruiz
makes the example of,
you know,
create enough self,
love enough,
self satisfaction enough inside yourself
that you don't need anything from
anybody else.
Your kitchen is fully stocked
so you're not starving.
You stock your own kitchen with your
own self fulfillment and then you don't
need to eat any little burger that comes
on the side of the road or something.
Hot Dog from a stand.
Whatever you can get
because you're starving.
You got plenty to eat.
And that's,
I think the analogy that we need to have.
We need to be full and whole and we need
to have standards as human beings we
accept of ourselves,
like what you shouldn't
accept from yourself.
Don't accept from yourself that you're
the guy that's going to be outside
someone's house at 3:00 in the morning,
shiny head light to their fucking
windows and throwing beer cans.
Don't accept that you're that guy.
You're not.
You can't be that guy if you're that guy.
No one's gonna come to you for advice.
No one's going to take you seriously.
You're.
You're a fucking dumb ass.
You're a dumb ass child
who gives into every whim.
It's like someone who comes
after one stroke every time.
I can't help,
but like you're a baby.
You're a fucking baby.
You learned some goddamn discipline.
Yeah,
it sucks.
Yeah.
You feel lonely?
You depressed.
Go on tinder stupid.
Fuck more chicks.
They're everywhere.
People want to fuck.
They love it.
That's why there's so many of us.
What are you doing,
man?
You telling me you get this one chick,
you can't get another check.
Go get another one.
Stupid,
and he will too.
That's the thing.
Do not have any friends,
not have any friends,
anybody that talks you
through it and goes,
do,
do.
Come on,
let's go.
So what?
People get so goddamn
connected when they date,
they get so fucking connected that they
feel like you stole something from them
who have been getting some
pleasure from another entity.
I'm tolerating it.
Sent us bust up your sleep patterns.
I'm going to fuck with your Beta waves.
So I'm going to kick your fucking
rem sleep right in the deck.
You fuck with me?
You fuck with
fallon?
It fucks with your sleep bank.
That's what he's doing.
He's a fucking baby.